check into the haunted hotel in Portland
right and I guess like the ninth floor
is the most haunted and so what floor
did they put us on good night you really
believe that
dude all Arcos we stopped these
plantations to hunt to hunt it goes oh
yeah all right seriously well oh no
seriously now let me show you boom
what's that EVP reported since the
electronic voice phenomena and you use
that to town ghosts Oh laugh if you want
but tell me have you guys ever been any
slave quarters before it's crazy okay
they got these like four foot ceilings
and they got these like he's changed
hanging off the walls and I'm telling
you you can feel it I mean these spirits
they want to be heard you hear them
yeah take you listen Eric hey
what the hell is this you know here well
no I I hear it I just don't hear it you
know listening bro yeah bro well I'm
done listening for today if you don't
believe me ask Sarah Oscar what she
believes in ghosts stop it Eric what
mean you've never told him tell me what